one more drink one more
drink you know in the morning
for sure we gonna stink one more
round one more round
it's
this is what we do catch up for a few
we'll riff and talk some [ __ ] and then
we'll sleep till two
[Music]
hey here we are we might be drunk
it's midday on a sunday it's beautiful
out in new york city
uh man yeah i'm uh what are you drinking
i need to know
oh by the way when you got a high chair
there what's that in the back you got
neck support
i got neck support because i got i've
been in physical therapy for my neck for
so
[ __ ] long i really agree wasn't that
expensive got it on amazon i just i just
researched
i i researched lumbar support and export
i'm a real [ __ ] [ __ ]
ah well you we're getting old but this
is the plight of the tall
man nobody talks about the negatives say
you know you get [ __ ]
you're playing basketball yeah you know
you win the presidency every president
has been taller
by the way who won
my mom also one time i told my mom i'm
depressed and she goes but you're tall
that's a bit that's right it's not a
carnival ride mom it's still you know
still can get sad here no you know it's
uh i do have back problems i'm like i'm
a tall lanky dude this is who it happens
to you know so
i don't people always are like you need
a good mattress you spend so much time
sleeping no one ever talks about a desk
chair ah
you're right you're right how much time
do we spend at the desk we're sitting
they say sitting is the new smoking
damn yeah not mine but i heard that
somewhere
damn that's heavy though i know because
you know nine of fives it's eight hours
of their life
sitting that's horrible for you i mean
how often do i i mean you must spend so
much of the day at a
thing even in a hotel room you're
sitting in that crappy chair and i'm
like
man it's not it's just not good for you
well when i write i walk i walk and talk
in the hotel room like a psycho
damn so you're just dictating into a
into a phone
a hairbrush uh can you believe uh who
are these people the whole night the
whole night who weren't these people
having my underwear with a hangover
holding a hairbrush
yeah no this chair is it's saving my
life man it still hurts but i do i do
the heating pad on my back at night i do
everything
oh i'm yeah i'm hardcore with everything
i want to make sure i just it doesn't go
because it goes out you're you can do
nothing for days so
right i mean you know what this is this
is the big you know my lady's got huge
knockers
and she's always like my back and i
can't fit in any clothing and we all go
yeah whatever you big titty horse shut
up we get it
it's the same with the tall guy we all
want to be tall and you're like my back
and we're like all right whatever
yeah but you can get a height
i reduction the line too from super bad
it was like the big line in the trailer
which like she had
she had a breast reduction she goes
that's like slapping god across the face
that was the line in the trailer oh
that's a good line
great line that one and the other line i
love from that movie is uh
i fingered that girl it was like hearing
the beatles for the first time or
whatever it was
that's such a great rock sleazy thing
mixed with like a mythical beautiful
thing that's great coming of age man
super bad
so so good yeah nothing better than
coming they mean so much to a kid i mean
when i saw those as my and my age i was
like these are the best movies ever
it's weird how the coming of age movie
has just changed over the years
i grew up like i know i was you know
obviously i'd see him in the theater but
like i grew up on 80s
dude comedies like revenge of the nerds
or porkies and it's like funny like
you rewatch porkys you're like this is
to a to a young person right now
imagine being like wait what yeah
like i'm not just talking like the
shower scene it's like it opens a guy
calls a jewish guy a [ __ ] and you're
just like
right and he doesn't even get it i mean
they're making fun of it he calls him a
kite he goes it's a kite you idiot
yeah that's what he's like you're not
even you're not even racist
you don't even know how to be racist
that was like the joke but it was like
yeah
yeah was that meat he was like the big
guy yeah
that's kind of a nice uh little nod to
the jews like we're going to give you
the
they could have gotten you a woody allen
type and they gave you the big guy
that's right i guess meat was a jew yeah
well you figure if it's going through
some producers maybe they did some some
casting
you gotta get the jack guy hey at least
i didn't go with stereotype yeah yeah
exactly
what are you drinking by the way i went
i went all in
it's day time it's winter
hot toddy oh my god
the lady cooked it up oh my god i love
that
that looks so good whiskey honey lemon
cinnamon
dude that is that's a win that is the
winter drink especially people
dining outdoors in february yes
exactly yeah we're under a heat lamp and
a fur coat so you need a
little extra warmth some places aren't
even doing the heat lamp i walked by
john's pizzeria the other day one of the
best pizza places in the city no doubt
but bleaker i'm bleaker yeah and
like yeah we don't do heat lamps like
it's 20 degrees and like
yeah we're good like they're like so
cocky about that
we'll make it work damn that's hard i
mean
thank god you can do 25 now the seller's
open diners are open
me and sally's went to a diner the other
day was like heaven oh yeah dude i'm
well i'm drinking a juice bomb ipa i've
never had this but we haven't done a
beer on the pod yet have we
no i don't think so we did the lemon
truly like a like a
homo but uh never done that i uh
this is good by the way i'm not a huge
ipa guy it's pretty good
here's the thing about ipa you learn
with age i think
i don't like them either but one is
great
yeah i'm the same way i'm not a big bee
i'm not like i'm beer's just not my
go-to i like hard stuff i like hard
liquor i like i like cocktails i like uh
beer yeah you drink 10 beers that's fine
when you're 18.
when you're in your 30s you're pissing
all night you're pissing all night it's
like you ate a loaf of bread
it's heavy you're burping i'm with you
as a kid it was like get a get a rack
get a package get a case
and now i'm like i'll have two or three
maybe
yeah oh sorry no no why
beer wasn't considered an alcoholic
beverage in russia until 2011.
is that real yeah fun fact
damn because they're just is it because
they're such vodka heads what is it
there's such booze bags over there that
yeah vodka is is like red wine to them
they have it with dinner they have it
with lunch
you know and so then beer was like this
is water
damn that's why that's why they're so
[ __ ] tough like in in wars
russians never quit and it's just they
just [ __ ] drink
i know i know it's same with like boxing
or maybe more ufc
but you know you always put black guy
toughest but then russian
is almost up to black
and toughness is that i mean yeah i mean
i always think of soda dan soder's old
bit about like there's nothing scarier
than a russian accent that was like
the classic that was like his bit that
like you couldn't follow that he would
kill
so hard that's such a great soda bit
because
he's he's a hilarious guy he's a good
comic but then he puts the voices on top
of the funny brain
it's kind of like kyle dunnigan right
man is he funny like those impressions
are so
good but he couldn't really find a way
into the comedy world then he got those
filters on and it was over well he was
working and he wrote for a ton of shows
you mean like
as like a social media guy yeah kyle's
been successful forever but uh
got one of my favorite jokes ever oh
really you know the joke he said uh
where they say some women think he is
too close a relationship with his mother
but but mom says all those women are
dirty little [ __ ]
that's great i love it he had the great
one about uh
the the crooners in the 40s like sinatra
and dean martin they
they have to seem so manly so they're
like i see the moon
and you're right hey oh watch out he's
basically saying like
i love you but oh i'm not gay i like
ladies i like women
i love [ __ ] that was the 50s sinatra
also kind of like aged into being the
tough guy i know he always said like
he's always a hoboken guy he was always
like a mob guy but he just didn't look
like a tough guy when he was super young
because he was like a string bean and
then you see him older like oh he also
like aged into his looks
you know oh yeah oh yeah he was so
skinny he had that that pronounced face
with the curly
slick hair but he was like a timberlake
who kind of went into
a soprano yeah that's true he also
i mean yeah he really uh
he fell off for a while too and i think
from hero to eternity saved his career
it's weird like acting saved him don't
you feel like acting kind of gave
timberlake a boost too though with like
social network it was like oh [ __ ] he's
kind of got
that i mean him on snl he was great
you're like wow this guy's funny
you didn't you didn't want him to be
funny because he's handsome he can sing
but then you're like he's good
yeah he makes fun of himself that's all
you all you want for someone who's been
famous since they were 12 or whatever
like mickey mouse club [ __ ] you're like
just laugh at yourself and you're in
that's all you have to do
yeah and it's also interesting this is a
weird
reach maybe but like when i was growing
up
timberlake was a punch line like oh
justin timberlake boy band douche
and girls would always go yeah yeah [ __ ]
that guy he's a dork
but they didn't mean it because
you know like he's bagged jessica beale
and cameron diaz and britney spears and
all these you know top shelf clams
but yet he was made fun of in his youth
but women
they'll throw that out there but they
don't mean it
yeah i think i also it's like you're in
a boy band but then like he kind of went
his own way and people started to like
him again
i think when you kind of do your own
thing it's weird how there's like five
of you
they're all working they're all
successful but one dude just [ __ ]
pops
yeah same as like destiny's child it's
not like i doubt the other two
are struggling but beyonce's [ __ ]
beyonce
yeah yeah good point i think you have to
hit the gas
like i don't know if they hit the gas
yeah it's like the other few it's like
the avengers like
you got you got iron man and then like
there's hawkeye hawkeye's still okay
yes that's perfect he ain't iron man
right
right yeah so true i mean it's batman
and superman
uh but the flash come on
that's all you got is flash yeah i hear
that show is good but i'm just like i
don't believe it
it's weird i i don't know i was never a
d i'm not a huge comic guy but
if i if as a kid i was and i i was
so more marvel than dc oh see i was
a dc guy why is that why do you think
well dc just felt i get it like marvel
is cool and
but dc felt classic i like the
classicness of it the cape
the the the blue and the red or the blue
and the gray
and i know i felt more humble marvel was
like oh this guy's got
a laser beam shooting out of his eye
like it felt too
too easy interesting see i was like
peter parker was shown new york like
spider-man he lived in queens he was a
photographer trying to make ends meet
he uh you know had the issues with his
folks uh
good point i love the beef with jonah
jameson i was such a spider-man guy as a
kid
but i liked i just never gave a [ __ ]
about superman like he was too powerful
he just could do everything so i'm like
all right if you could stop bullets and
like i don't give a [ __ ]
but then batman i was always like yeah
batman's cool i mean
those movies with michael keaton and
jack nicholson growing up
and like those are [ __ ] great great
and also new york basically i mean they
call it gotham but let's be honest
and also i'm with you on spider-man but
spider-man again he feels classic
i like that timeless kind of vibe but
you know you start bringing in
night crawler and beast and uh all these
[ __ ] rules dude oh
that's just a big gay guy with no shirt
on i don't know beast was
like a gorilla i like that he's like the
intellectual of the group and you're
like he's gay
that's the [ __ ] guy he was like the
well-read guy
the x-men were cool because it was like
stan lee is so smart he was like this
will be about immigrants
and about like you know right it's like
this is people who are like different
they're like
but so society has to like brush them
away yes
but then he just made them like
superheroes so everyone's like that's
where the dumb people won't notice that
but
uh i thought x-men i mean wolverine was
the [ __ ] man come on every kid love
wolverine
every kid love wolverine and i grew up
in a black neighborhood wolverine was
the most popular
action guy amongst uh black kids they
loved wolverine
i don't know what it is but you know
what he just cuz he was a badass
and he like was damaged he was cool
because he was like the vulnerable guy
like cyclops
sucked everyone [ __ ] hated cyclops
yeah everybody
cuz he's whiny andy got the girl
aha good point good point and take the
sunglasses off inside
we got it you douche but yeah no you're
right
yeah why couldn't he just wear regular
glasses that stopped the lady you could
make sunglasses that can stop the laser
but not like
chill out dude [ __ ] jack nicholson
ain't that cool okay
and then wolverine was like the cool guy
who didn't get the girl he's [ __ ]
in casablanca he's he's the guy that we
like
wow great point way to make uh these
comic books
intellectual and interesting you're so
right also
wolverine was short for the record
and he was like he was just a bad like
also i think there's something cool
about like you think about even like in
war like who gets the most props and
wards like the people on the field it's
like the people in the combat
wolverine was like an up close guy like
swiping at you with his claws
cyclops stayed back from a distance
shooting you there's something cooler
about the dude who gets his paws dirty
so to speak you know i completely agree
and you can tell you read a lot this is
such a great literary breakdown
oh no whatever oh really that's a great
point never thought about the
hand-to-hand thing
and he had stubble cyclops clean-shaven
which tells you everything dirty didn't
care about his looks that much he was
[ __ ]
you know yeah over hugh jackman also
like i actually never saw logan i hear
logan's great but
but hugh jackman was like perfect for
perfect
like how do you cast a better wolverine
i know he's jacked he's great in it he's
he seems troubled and brooding that's
another thing that's great about
wolverine is he seems a little tortured
where cyclops
was like get out of my way you're right
he's
you know cyclops is like guy pierce in
la confidential
and wolverine is like he's like russell
crowe
yeah wow you nailed it because
cyclops is like trying to climb the
ladder almost he's like i'm the i'm the
leader around here and
russell crowe just like let's just
[ __ ] take care of business right
right
right yeah let's i want action i want
results cyclops feels like he would
he yeah he feels like he would return
something at a restaurant like
or have a part of a horrible order like
croutons on the side
only you know what do you have oat milk
all that
exactly i bet like i felt like of all
the x-men cyclops had a business card
you know he's like here's my card right
i was a gambit guy but he was getting
[ __ ] ruled yeah from new orleans
cajun he had the cards
the stick something fun trench coat
gambit was awesome too because in the
cartoon he was always like the
the badass but he always got his ass
kicked he was like the dispenser were
like all right i guess
amber gets [ __ ] up in the scene right
he just always got the [ __ ] kicked out
of him
yeah man stan lee
what a genius i mean genius what's cool
about stan lee is you can tell
it's almost like joke writing where
something happens to us we're like oh
yeah why is that we write it down
he probably lost his temper on his wife
and he was like the hulk
you know like aha i got something here
yeah he just came out of a blackout and
ripped short she was like this is it
yeah yeah right right oh that that could
be something there
but yeah jew from brooklyn by the way
yeah
[ __ ] that's crazy and like aviarad all
those like marvel dudes are like
they must just all be so [ __ ] smart
he was bankrupt dude marvel i remember
they had he had no money in the 90s they
were
failing and blade brought it back of all
the comics
yeah whoa how about that and by the way
i'm pretty sure i'm right on that but i
know people they're [ __ ] bigger nerds
about this [ __ ] i'm
i'm not a big comic book nerd but those
these are people going to be writing
like it wasn't blade you idiot all right
i'm sorry it's a drinking show some of
our facts aren't
100 check but i do believe it was blade
and then those new spider-man movies
with
toby maguire oh yeah that was huge
those were huge huge i saw that in the
theater isn't that weird how you hear
about these places going bankrupt like
marvel's going bankrupt marvel's been
around my whole life they've been on tv
they've been in movies
like ben and jerry's filed for
bankruptcy in like 2001. i'm like they
did they're everywhere
i don't understand bankruptcy go into
one store that doesn't have ben and
jerry's
i know i don't understand it 7-eleven
filed for bankruptcy in 98 or something
they're everywhere
i don't understand how money works me
neither
yeah yeah that's why we we're our own
business drinking
no microphone well yeah that's
interesting man yeah marvel files for
bankruptcy those those toby maguire ones
he's a weird dude because i don't know
if you ever see that aaron sorkin movie
uh [ __ ] the one molly's game
no i got a thing for that lady but never
saw it oh yeah she's hot but uh and
she's [ __ ]
a great actress but uh uh yeah it's like
a badass
real woman the story the story is insane
where she's like you know was an olympic
athlete she was a some sort of skier i
don't know the right term but like she
i think broke her back or something and
then ends up like
working the way back she like starts
running this card game with all these
celebrities
and this one guy it's played by michael
sarah in the movie he's such a [ __ ]
[ __ ] that i start going down like a
youtube
like a whatever like a google search
like who is this guy based on and like
it's tobey maguire
so he's doing these like weird dark card
games and he was like
i'm like if this dude's that big an
[ __ ] he is a terrible
it's so funny you know what's funny it's
that he's like such a
he's such an aw shucks guy it's like you
see him in like pleasantville and he's
like oh
deary me and you're like that's the dude
that's the [ __ ]
right exactly so it's like it's like
cosby
you know pull your pants up don't curse
and then nighttime comes around and he's
making you a cocktail it's so true
it's always the opposite [ __ ] like uh
i heard tobey maguire leonardo dicaprio
and david blaine
would go around new york in the early
90s when they were kind of starting to
pop
and they called themselves the [ __ ]
party and they would go to like the les
and just hit those bars and just pick up
girls all night
and they were like they had the cute one
they had the the dark quiet one and then
they had like the sexy one who was leo
and they cleaned up
damn that is a pretty formidable three
though you got the two actors in the
magic
the magician is great for probably just
disarming women
with uh just like matt he's just doing
magic and yeah
all right i mean like i've seen uh
magicians do that [ __ ] we were like
but he got oh yeah it's funny i always
want to do a bit i never did this but
like
uh david blaine got uh he got like two
me too
accusations or something and and they
just mysteriously went away and you're
like man either he's a monster he's a
he's a damn fine magician
i made that disappear that's easy even
uh siegfried and roy were like goddamn
what's his name uh copperfield
copperfield no i gotta be
going vegas yeah he's [ __ ] you're
impressed with the statue of liberty and
that even that lady was hard to keep
quiet
what uh man that hot toddy looks good
too
a daytime buzz i'll take a daytime oh
nothing better nothing better like when
i was a kid we used to go to the
this park in north audubon park and just
getting drunk in the park dude yeah
right by tulane actually i buy the
trolley
yes and we would just get drunk on the
benches and just something about that
sunshine on your face at 3 p.m with like
after like four
tall boys that was that was living [ __ ]
yeah there's something about a
daytime drunk where you're just like
with your boys in the park
yeah we've done a couple of times at
central park or wherever we do we're
just like hanging out having a beer
i remember we went to that yankees game
[ __ ] last year it feels like 10 years
ago but it was like a year ago
wow we got blotto on that i mean i went
ten that was all beer too that was like
ballpark beers something about a
baseball game man
there's something so damn special about
a daytime baseball game
because even if you're not in the
baseball you're just
having a good ass time yeah it's just
the best especially
i don't mind the nosebleed you know it's
just bleachers you're with your guys
you're drinking
you're yelling you're not really
bothering anybody the sun is shining
it feels like america i'll tell you why
i think baseball is the only sport
where the nosebleeds are better and
here's my argument
tickets are so expensive these sporting
events you get [ __ ] you
you go to the nosebleeds you get a big
crew of your friends
right yes you're not doing that in the
you know right behind home plate seats
also you don't there's not as much
pressure on the game
there's 162 baseball games this season
you don't need to like
we don't need to be locked into every
pitch yes so that way you're just like
you're watching the game but you're also
like socializing so it's like almost
like
that's why it's called the ballpark it's
a day at the park you're just hanging
yes
exactly and you can yeah you can take a
break and
also there's a lot of timeouts there's a
lot of switches and they they switch
teams and all that there's so much down
time in a baseball game
oh yeah i love it dude yeah the the
seventh inning stretch
the [ __ ] i i love i miss i miss
sporting events big time like that's
something i'm when that's back
i'm i'm taking full advantage man yeah
yeah same
and uh i feel like with uh your your
agent he can really get some tickets wow
let's hope let's let's go to some
let's go to some new you too let's
[ __ ] let's
scratch my [ __ ] i'll scratch yours yeah
let's get those michael chase seats i
mean he's an anti-semite now
a transphobe uh he got he got lit up on
twitter i saw that
yeah again i do too i was like
this guy got yelled at by being a
transphobe a week ago and this week he
got yelled at by
the right so i'm like that's a comic
he's doing it right i love him he's such
a good dude and he's so funny
uh i know i remember he took i remember
christmas day game
he took me rachel feinstein and phil
hanley to a game and we're like got the
snl seats beautiful
and shay is just so fun to go to games
with because he's like a real fan but
he's also just down to drink and he's
cool
and i remember we're watching the
celtics it was a year they had this guy
isaiah thomas he's five foot nine
so imagine like phil's not into hoops
really but he's watching he's like this
guy's so tiny and then he just lights us
up you're like it's incredible to see a
dude who's five foot nine
live yeah on a show so yeah i was so
damn i've had so many
fun like basketball nights with that
dude i love i love che
jay's the man loved jay i hope he's
doing all right i mean
i hope he's just laughing all this off
but uh i don't think he's the type to
even check social media is he good
good i i know yeah
i think it bothered him you know five
years ago when it started and he just
like
okay people are crazy got it moving on
i'm getting more and more like that
where like
i'll post and look less yeah like i i
used to like be like i wonder how this
is performing now i'm kind of like i
thought it was funny
i'm putting it up i don't want to get
stuck in it i
i used to get i used to just go to my
email the youtube comments i shut that
the [ __ ] down i don't want to see any of
them
oh no no delete that but yeah they call
it post and ghost
that's the move yeah let me just run
this by we mentioned day drunk
high school with your guy friends did
you have a high school uniform
i had to wear a blazer and a tie when i
was in high school yeah
wow that's heavy duty it was funny yeah
man well i had to wear a white button
down and gray slacks and black shoes but
that was always a big thing was like
when you got in trouble in high school
like you stole something from a
convenience store
or drinking in the park you had the
uniform on so you always it always got
drawn back to the the principal yeah i
remember
uh but then also they're like if you're
like 17 18
and you're smoking a cigarette they're
like yeah it must be like a businessman
you know you're in a tie
yeah that's true i i remember this one
kid had an
inflatable bong in high school it was
like a [ __ ] that's how [ __ ]
like you know most kids are like oh well
smoke a joint it'll look like a
cigarette walk down the street this
kid's like i got an inflatable bong
we'll go to central park
and we'll smoke so he would he would
literally blow it up
yeah and it would be a [ __ ] and we
would just take rips in central park i'm
like this is so
if we get arrested there's a dumbest
[ __ ] we didn't think about it we're like
yeah
it'll work out could you pop it when he
when the cops showed up or something
i don't know i mean i think i think once
they search you you're [ __ ]
like how do you get the mechanic how do
you light a plastic
it had a little metal had a little metal
thing you put into it but it blew up to
like form the uh
had a metal thing to hold the weed and
yeah yeah i see wow that's pretty good
beer bong for the lady saving silverman
yes holy [ __ ] are we the biggest [ __ ]
nerds i mean like i i definitely i think
that's an underrated flick by the way
oh so good i mean steve zahn's a beast
yeah he's like kind of like a journey
man like kind of deserves
he's in one of my favorite movies called
out of sight oh yeah we've talked about
that before yeah
but yeah saving silverman man [ __ ]
jack black rules jack black is great the
whole neil diamond through line is
hilarious and amanda pete was funny and
so hot
too she's like one of the hottest
actresses ever
i agree yeah that's a great great comedy
and steve zahn and sam rockwell are on
the same level of like
i just want to do good work and i don't
have to be tom cruise but
uh i just want to be in movies and do
well yeah but that's that's a good point
never thought of him like that but i bet
like when there's a guy who's like kind
of like you in that way it [ __ ]
they're like all right we'll take
rockwell he's more famous or something
yeah
probably probably but they're both so
good man
all right let's read this ad here let's
read this ad we got it we got an ad for
honey
man this is uh i'm excited i actually
use this product so this pretty do you
ever use it
oh yeah love the honey honey uh
because you know when you're online and
you check out and you're like that's
kind of expensive
this thing you just downloaded and
and it it just goes into your browser so
it just automatically gets you the best
deal i mean it's kind of incredible
it's a it's a genius idea the browser
extension that fills in promo codes
when you shop online it works with
wine.com and walgreens
which sells beer and all those places so
uh
just throw it in there and you're good
to go we all shop online and having a
promo code ready to go is tough but
thanks to honey
i don't have to search for codes anymore
honey is free browser extension that
scours the internet for promo codes when
you're ready to check out
honey automatically applies the best one
to your cart
instant savings honey has found it's
over 17 million members over two billion
dollars in savings wow
that's huge and if you don't already
have honey you could sort of be missing
out on free savings it's literally free
it installs in a few seconds
and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid and supporting this
podcast so get honey it's free join
honey dot com slash drunk
that's honey.com slash drunk
i love that broncos our code yeah yeah
right the drunks get on it folks because
uh
i i uh grew up with my mom clipping
coupons at the counter like at the
checkout i was like
come on lady i got this you know my
mom's got big glasses like hang on hang
on she brought the scissors from home it
was so brutal
this is great and and it really you
really do save money on i've used it a
lot and uh i haven't i have it just set
up
so i i highly recommend it honey.com get
on that folks
get on it what uh give me a wreck
cause i know you're watching stuff i've
been watching your ex and loving them by
the way
oh great yeah people are writing in
saying the wrecks are helping them
because
we're all you know we all need content
we all need [ __ ] to watch but uh
this week i finished lady and the dale i
don't know if you saw it i loved it i
watch it because of you
amazing amazing it's it's so
[ __ ] good it's crazy these true
stories it's kind of like wild wild
country i don't know if you ever saw
that one
i missed that one i got to get on that
that one's good it's on netflix still
it's about these
nut jobs in oregon who start a cult and
you're like this all happened and i'm
like mom did you know about that she's
like i don't know
that's how little you know you watched
the five o'clock news it was a half hour
you moved on
but now we know about everything so it's
weird that we're just going back in time
and taking all these news stories that
are just
gems of entertainment and stretching
them out for netflix or whatever hbo
yeah it's also they use like stop-motion
animation i think it's called
they did that in the billboard
documentary american which i also love
bill
hicks not bill bill hicks yeah i love
that incredible uh
doc but uh yeah dude tucker it's like
catch me if you can
but a trans woman yeah yes yes that's
great that's the pitch in the uh in the
elevator catch me if you can
we're the trans yeah but it's it's kind
of
like i mean i don't want to just no i'll
give away spoilers on this but it's kind
of incredible that like
her just her love for family
like being this kind of morally
questionable person
but you still kind of it's weird when
you're watching a doc you almost watch
it like it's a regular movie a scripted
movie and you kind of root for the
person
because she had the charm yes
a great actor playing who would have had
and to be a con man you have to have
that charisma i guess
yeah good point i mean everybody in that
auto shop was like we trusted her
to the death like we were we thought we
were making the next great american car
and blah and she was fighting off ford
and gm
and detroit all these guys she she was
awesome
awesome and it's also funny that like
that guy
who brought her down was tucker
carlson's dad because i'm watching this
dude i'm like i [ __ ] hate this dude i
don't know why i hate this guy so much
but the way he he like look i'm not
going to begrudge him for following the
story you're you're a journalist
and it's a juicy [ __ ] story take that
to the bank
do it but the glee he felt and the and
like the joy he felt calling her a man
i'm like oh you're just kind of an
[ __ ] you're just like getting off
on being an [ __ ] and he looks
horrible i mean like if karma's real he
looks like [ __ ] jabba the hutt i was
expecting his like last
interview to be like
[Music]
disgusting looking but uh totally
it's it's i mean if that's the movie
he's like josh brolin and milk like he's
the bad guy yes exactly isn't it amazing
how
we have all these great stories and
fiction and movies but when you watch
these docs you're like
it's so obvious who these these tropes
and archetypes are based on like they're
all just right there that's the bad guy
he looks like the bad
that's the good guy it's fun it's that's
why documentaries are great because
you're like it's a story
but it's real it's so real and and it's
a great point because
sh what she did is much worse than what
he did he's just a journalist doing his
job yeah
yeah but i for some reason understood
her and i didn't really understand him
because i'm like look i'm not gonna like
i would never do what she
did i would never like try to like just
rip people off out of money
but like you get what she was trying
like her motives made more
sense to me than his right or maybe his
motives made more sense
but he was a dick about it and she
wasn't maybe that's what it was
that's really interesting it's all about
intent versus
the thing you said you know she's she's
actually lying and and conniving people
but she has
good intentions where he has regular
intentions but he's a dick yeah
and also and also she like was all about
her [ __ ]
like i feel so bad for her kids you
could just
there's like the one girl who seems like
fairly well adjusted
but the rest you're like they're just
broken without it and it was weird to me
that like this
uh this con artist it's funny to like
say uh connor dina hashem has this great
joke my friend dean hashem is this great
joke about how like
trump is a con man and liberals prefer a
con
artist oh like that's why they don't
like him like
conservatives are okay with the con man
liberals are like we want you to earn it
like we want
to be it's a funny bit but right great
catch
but it's funny it's like i say con man
i'm like maybe that's like
do you think like now the police are
getting more woke to like there's a con
man like
it's a con person okay this is the con
it could be either you know right but
i've noticed they don't really do that
hey
or a woman you know there's a ton of
male 1
serial killers out there and women
her name was francine the strangler
actually so
exactly no that's a good that's a good
catch yeah it's and it's really like
um you know it's an incredible
documentary there's hbo is killing it
right now hbo
duploss brothers they're i think they're
number one because
netflix is almost like this grab bag
like just throw a bunch of [ __ ] in
something will stick and look they have
some great stuff but hbo is hand-picked
it's like the it's like the whole foods
versus key food key food's got some
great [ __ ] but you got to sift
interesting yeah my wreck is it's taco
is a
lady i almost said tucker and the dale
tucker and dale versus evil good good
movie as well but
what is that your record what's your
right well my wreck is uh
first of all have you seen the patrice
dock i i'm gonna watch it
when it's online i can't do the
commercials i haven't i haven't seen it
either so don't don't feel weird so i'm
with you but i should throw that out
there just as
everybody should watch that he's one of
the great watch elephant in the room
it's fun
one of the best comics of all time
patrice o'neill
we've both been lucky enough to perform
at the patrice o'neill benefit that bill
burke
is in new york one of the great gigs i
mean what a great guy bill burr is that
he
he puts on a theater benefit every year
and gives the proceeds to
you know patrice's family i mean just an
incredible guy so shout out to bill burr
and
all the clips i've seen are incredible
we've got all these great comics talking
about yeah
patrice and and and reminiscing it looks
it looks incredible like okay i just
comedy central it's like just [ __ ]
put it out without adds man i know i
know put it on youtube for [ __ ] sake
that's comedy central they always gonna
turn the knife
but yeah and they turned it on good
people shout out to like we're grateful
for the people comedy center who are
good to us
for sure but but they did them wrong i
agree
i agree the structure i'm with you and
patrice
what i love about patrice is uh
everybody i've talked to was like he was
a mean guy he was scary he was a dick
but i love that we can look past that
because the act is so good the comedy is
so important and so funny and so
uh innovative and new and original that
we're still like yeah yeah but we gotta
we gotta showcase this
that's such a great point because i
think we romanticize like
the wrong comedian sometimes or at least
the public does and and
charm is so often overrated like when
who gets
the big specials this guy's so charming
but the material is horseshit
whereas didn't give a [ __ ] about charm
yes
all about the product and right and that
is
that's special because charm is
overrated charm is like you know who's
charming
[ __ ] used car salesman deadbeat
they're charming
okay bundy was charming exactly charm is
[ __ ] patrice didn't care about charm
he cared about execution
and about delivering the best possible
products and that's why
elephant in the room is one of the best
specials of all time amazing amazing
special
and i think it also is a good sign for
things in comedy going the right way
because
we're very feelings based which i get
and feelings are important and all that
but like
good has got to be good too we got to
have some kind of standard
so i think that's a it's a good sign
that this came out that's a great point
good you want good to make it to the top
and enough with like
this guy is like he's got the it factor
the [ __ ] industry
loves to they love to and here's the
thing all these [ __ ] industry [ __ ]
spineless [ __ ] who are like yes
is the best yeah where were you when he
was alive you [ __ ] sticks
you know exactly all these people like
patrice is my favorite comic
oh really even network's job why didn't
you help him
yeah exactly they all say i love george
carlin
you would never book him now he would
never put on him on anything now an old
white guy who's saying the truth
get the [ __ ] out of here exactly
yes well patrice kept it real and all
these people who uh
here's the brilliance of patrice to me
is like you didn't have to like what he
was saying
for you to enjoy the special oh yeah
yeah and that is that's special now when
all these comedians who think they're
edgy as [ __ ]
then they just go on the road and
they're just playing for like-minded
people
the setups are killing where they're
like i think this should be a thing and
everyone applauds
okay well then why don't you be a
[ __ ] preacher or a pundit yes
go do a ted talk this is this is joke
jokes it says comedy on the side of the
wall here like come on bring with the
hahas
and also we're so big into uh it's like
you said agreeance and if if it's not
the way i think it's wrong and that's
what i love i don't agree with
everything patrice says but it's still
brilliant and well thought out and well
written and well executed so i think i
disagree with him on a shitload of his
points on women and i'm still laughing
like i'm like oh i don't know but he'll
say that my women i'm like oh i don't
date like i don't
date women like that you know like i'm
saying like i disagree with that but i'm
laughing my ass off because
he's a brilliant comedian like
undeniably funny and that's to me what's
special about patrice is like
rock does this too where like you get to
a point where like you'll say something
[ __ ] up
in the setup and people even your own
fans are like
that's not no and then by the end 30
seconds later they're like all
applaud and you're like that's
incredible that yes
that a joke can do that that through
humor you can
uh you can deliver this
almost this message but it's through
laughter where like
people are agreeing with you through
feeling good
yeah that's what comedy's supposed to be
i i saw a rock at the cellar this is
five six years ago and he had this bit
about how he's like we do all this [ __ ]
about how it's hard to be a woman it's
way harder to be a man
way harder to be a man already the crowd
is furious all the women are like
folded arms like all right let's hear it
and he does this
tap dance and then by the end of it he's
like ladies
somebody pulls up with the refrigerator
box and they need help bringing it down
the stairs
you ain't helping and that was like a
big punchline
i'm butchering it but it was like this
brilliant way to get it together
and uh it killed and that's comedy
i've told this story a million times but
like i remember i was like probably 12
or something
i'm in my you know my with my dad's
parents in uh boston for thanksgiving
i'm i have a good cd player i've rock's
album roll with the new
and i'm listening to it just laughing i
probably don't get half the jokes i'm a
kid
but maybe younger than 12 who knows but
my mom sees me laughing she's like what
is she laughing at i want to know what
he's listening she grabs my headphones
and starts listening
and then look on horror on my mom's face
she was just like and then i watch her
listen for like another 20 30 seconds
and i see her start laughing i'm like
that's [ __ ] great that right rock can
do that
you know that like that's that's so cool
to see as a kid
that someone could say something
provocative and shocking and you're like
no and then a minute later you're like
oh wow that they almost like it's almost
like a bait it's almost like the way a
realtor will be like
we have all this great stuff in the
apartment you get there and it's shitty
yeah is doing the opposite
yeah you know he's like this apartment
sucks and you walk in and then it's
amazing
all right right so true so true
man that was a great little comedy break
down there
because that's what i just watched
coming to america because the new one's
coming out
i like i grew up with that movie i love
that movie by the way that was never
like a black comedy i just thought it
was [ __ ] great and hilarious and
andy murphy was the king whatever but
every joke is like their luggage gets
stolen right when they get to new york
the landlord's a piece of [ __ ] he rips
them off the guy
ponytail i mean they're just getting
screwed every left and right
they do it they go to the nightclub
they're talking all these gross women
these annoying women these
whatever one woman's got a dick and it's
all a joke i'm like this is what comedy
is
it's supposed to be this where it's just
getting your [ __ ] stolen is horrible
and they they try to sell to him the guy
comes up with a trench coat i got some
good [ __ ] here and he's like you're a
thief
that's the joke and that's what that's
what everything is it's horrible [ __ ]
making light of it
you're so right it's it's basically rock
i mean uh eddie murphy and arsenio
coming they're royalty
and then they come to new york and
they're just [ __ ] nobody and that's
like
that's what comedy is you should be it
should be egalitarian you should be
one with all the [ __ ] people in the
[ __ ] that's what a good stand-up show
is
yeah that's why when you become too
[ __ ] famous you lose track of reality
and you become unrelatable
yes completely exactly exactly
all right so let me get my wreck so we
we went off
on a tangent that's all right i love a
tangent but
uh i want to throw this show your honor
oh we're on a different page already you
saw it
ugh oh i thought the first episode was i
here's what i like about it
it's cheesy it's way over the top but
i'm a little new orleans biased but
you're very new orleans bias
the the the villain is so so ridiculous
michael stillberg i love good actor but
it's just so
heavy-handed and you get it you're
whatever you're brooding
it's bad lighting we get it you're rich
and evil but the
way it gets you thinking like all right
your kid got
killed so you hate this guy but he's
trying to protect his kid
so the writing isn't great but the way
it makes you think like all right
you want your way but you want your way
and you're going to do whatever you want
to get your way and just all the lying
is fun to keep up with i'll tell you
what i hate about it
all right please i almost hate it's a
strong word cranston's
one of the best actors ever and i love
him i love him so much and i i love that
actor michael stillberg from uh a
serious man he's in
oh yeah he's in a shape of water he's a
great he's like one of those actors
where like i bet no one knows that
dude's name
but everyone's like oh that guy which is
a great actor
right yeah serious man is underrated by
the way oh my god the clone brothers are
[ __ ] geniuses
yeah but uh you know uh
i just thought the it was just so doer
and over the top and like the beginning
the beginning when it's like it's 20
minutes in if you think there's a
spoiler but like
someone dies and the way they die like
he coughs
you think he's gonna wish for something
just coughs up blood it's just so
it's like we get it like you created the
most depressing
relentlessly severe [ __ ] of all time it
to me it like makes up for good writing
the first scene with brian cranston
it's like he's like let me show you i'm
a good guy
by by like i'm so committed to my job i
jogged into the [ __ ] hood and i
i i looked at it to me it was just like
all right this is
to me not for me that's all i'll say
yeah yeah it
look i get it it's not uh it's not
breaking bad
it definitely are not on that level but
well that's the thing with him is like
when you when you're in breaking bad
you're comparing
but i love it i loved him in trombone
which i think is like not a great
not a great movie but i loved him in it
i think he's incredible in it
but just the beauty of the movie or the
show is just the uh the inner weaving of
like all right how's he gonna get out of
this one how's it going out of this one
and they they find
ways and that's what's cool it's not
it's not the dialogue for sure
it's not really the character
development it's like
oh they did some real weaving it's
almost like a whodunit where you're like
this is a little silly but
i kind of want to see how he gets out of
it how many epson are you
ah five and it and you're still pleased
with it
it stays good to you i'm still pleased
with it because of that
that point i made because i'm watching
with the lady going this is stupid
that's
that doesn't make sense but i like the
this guy's trying to cover his ass but
he's trying to cover his ass and we say
he's a good guy but is he a good guy and
what do people do in their backs against
the wall
all that stuff's fun i like i don't mind
the idea of like
the the judge who's morally questionable
and the mafioso who's been done dirty
like to me that's
kind of interesting i just think the
execution sucks i'm just not
feeling it but i mean uh i'm with you
i'm with you i
chewed out gary veeder for telling me to
watch it the other day
a good buddy gary veto got an earful
from me
but my wreck is uh i don't know if
you've seen this yet
i have you seen uh judas and the black
messiah on hbo max
i have i've gotten a couple wrecked
lucas brothers who i'm friends with
i love them right they wrote it they're
first off i love the lucas brothers
personally so i was
yeah it's like one of the things we were
like i'm rooting for this going in
yeah and i was so satisfied it's so so
good it's such a
it's a really difficult subject to make
a movie about
the actors i mean daniel kahlua and
lakeith stanfield are such good actors
so
you know they just bring it even though
like i think daniel kahlua has like got
to be
i i don't know what was that it's got to
be in his 30s and he plays
fred hampton who died at 21 so he's got
to be like but like
it doesn't matter he's so good you're
just like all right i mean what 21 year
old actor is going to [ __ ]
nail that you know so yeah yeah exactly
but
it i heard it was kind of scorsese with
the shooting
you know what's interesting that's a
great point i think shaka king directed
it and it's like
it's got a lot of similarities to the
the departed to me because it's okay
uh it's better it's it's about a rat oh
you don't like the departed well i i
like it but again it's way over the top
it's silly we got a cheese eating rats
i mean like all right jack we got it
yeah but you know what throwing
coke on the vagina of the lady like come
on but dude the script is hilarious
wahlberg and alec baldwin are hilarious
see i can deal with over the top if the
dialogue's really good
right right right yeah yeah and there's
fun there's a lot of fun
your honor doesn't have any fun it's
just like suspense relentless it's not
fun like
you for me with dark shows you got to
release some tension you got to give me
like a laugh every once in a while
so anyway there's great dialogue in this
movie too i mean
lucas brothers killed it uh there's a
line that's great where you know he's
fred hampton's talking all these black
panthers he goes wars politics
with bloodshed and politics is war
without bloodshed
it's like great lines like that where
you're like all right good um
if you know what else it made me laugh
because there's like different chapters
to the black panthers
so it made me think of comedy where like
they'd be like i'm i'm the head of the
new haven black
panthers chapter and they look like yeah
but you'll never make it in new york
you know what i mean yeah yeah you have
a different vibe here you know
right it's i gotta watch is this netflix
hbo max oh hbo once again killing it
but uh yeah it's a good movie it's a
it's it's relentless and it's tense but
it's also
like it earns it man i also i'll give a
true story with that [ __ ] more
there's some scenes where you're like
damn this is pretty memorable like this
is pretty pretty damn good
all right i can't wait i'll watch it
tonight because i need i need a new
movie i've blown through and everything
and
the lucas brothers are so fascinating
because these hipster twins
who are very funny on stage but they're
like obsessed with
philosophy they read kierkegaard and
nietzsche and all these guys
and i'm mired in philosophy so i love
that [ __ ]
but they're so deep these dude these two
dudes but their act is kind of
you know it's it's very surface bubble
gummy they got eight minutes on uh
eve six and sublime and all this [ __ ]
and
uh they'll talk about like shaquille
o'neal they'll be silly on stage but
yeah but you know look they know how to
kill on stage and that's important you
know i mean
they're uh they're really funny dudes
but they also
i hear you like it's hard to go up there
and talk [ __ ] you know
lou zoo on stage like what do you want
exactly i still say everybody talks
about the k sound is the funniest sound
i think the oo
sound comedy he said lao zoo i lost it
funny what sounds are funny sounds are
funny
um well accents are funny they're
they're it's a good movie i'm proud of
that
it was like one thing i'm watching i'm
like i hope it's good because i i'm like
i'm always nervous to watch [ __ ] that
friends make because i'm just like
and i'm not like super tight with them
but i've always liked them a lot and
they're always
like if i see them at the show we'll
share for one they're just like
cool dudes so yeah it's cool that they
made something so good
and uh and i think they worked on it for
years years and years to get it made
because
wow you know it's hard to get a movie
made oh don't get me yeah hollywood's a
nightmare that those
tunnels you gotta go through so good for
them and i'm gonna watch tonight i can't
wait
give me a peeve dawg ah peeve
well i got a big one and i got a small
one i love it
all right i'll go the small one first uh
i don't know
if you've seen this or if you hate this
but
i got a real problem with people
throwing trash in the sink
ooh like what kind you know like
somebody will uh is this about your
girlfriend
well it is but i had a friend who did
this in college and
he was a roommate and it drove me
[ __ ] nuts like he would he would
throw
uh like uh an orange peel in the sink
or he would throw a balled up napkin in
the sink like oh i'm done with this
throw it in the sink and you're like
hey this ain't no garbage disposal this
is just a drain
you can't throw an orange peel to sink
you can't throw a wrapper in the sink
he's not a garbage can he's a drain he
stinks
yes that's all yeah it's awful it's
unacceptable
have you seen this of course yeah okay
roommates do that yeah it's
it's unacceptable i mean it's not a
guard it's basically saying
here's you clean this [ __ ] up that's
what it is yeah it's like somebody has
to pull that out of there
yeah that's unacceptable that's
unacceptable
unacceptable little one for sure i
support this
i can see how the brain is like oh
that's where you dump your cheerios out
so i you know your brain starts getting
accustomed to like putting
bad [ __ ] discarded [ __ ] in there but it
you can't throw a wrapper in there
this is a garbage can why like why are
you doing it i hate it i hate it what's
the best all right
the big one and this one has been
covered to death by
a million people but i i just hate it so
much that i got to bring it up
loud music in a restaurant what are you
doing to me
all i want to do here is talk we got to
scream we got to yell or at a bar
like super loud music what's the point i
it's one of my biggest pet peeves thank
you
it's the worst it's unacceptable and i i
feel like it's because
like i used to like laugh when my mom
would complain about it and now i'm just
like oh it's the worst like it's
i think it's because especially for
people like us like we're so used to
leading with
comedy and her personality like even
trying to pick up a girl was never like
my face that did it it was like a funny
line i feel like i had that would like
break the ice and it's it's rendering
our personalities
useless yes yes you know what it feels
like when you're on stage and the mic
goes out and they're like just yell so
you have to yell your act and it's never
the same because
now you're yelling yeah and your your
timing is off
the inflection is off so it's the worst
because you're just like
huh vodka soda you know you're like who
enjoys this
who is this for like we can have music
but just lower it
it's such a good point that's so true
you're you're it throws your timing off
and it's a comedian
timing you feel like is everything not
only that
but i remember we'd be at comedy
festivals and all the parties would be
like the music would be so loud good
point yeah we'd all that we'd lose our
voices and i'd be like hey man yes
we need our voices this week we're
performing for [ __ ]
all the industry people on tuesday
monday night there's a party like
why are you doing this to us i know i
know and then
here's here's the next level of it you
go you tell the waiter hey could you
could you lower it they're like
whoa we got real uh squaresville over
here what are you
the reverend footloose like no i just uh
i'm just
i can't talk i'm yelling yeah i'm the
rev i'm a reverend in footloose i don't
want to just like have a
i came here to talk to my friend yes
you feel like a girl who went out to
sincerely talk to her friend
at a bar and the guy was like then why
are you here you like that dude
then why are you here and like i just
want to catch up with my friend over a
drink they're like
sure you did sure i know i know i mean
dive bars got it right just some smooth
jazz in the back or like a little piano
whatever uh or even some rock i don't
give a [ __ ] just
keep it it should be an atmosphere thing
we're we're here to hang
give me some music like i'm solving a
murder in the 50s that's what i [ __ ]
want for background
i want some light jazz maybe you know
what there's nothing better in the
winter to me
then you walk into a bar and it's like
wood
wood panels and [ __ ] and they're playing
sinatra and you're like oh i feel
like that warms me instantly love it
love it sinatra or some motown
something yeah something low-key softer
i'm totally with you why are we yelling
why are we and
it's almost like when you when you when
the you know when every now and then
there's a band and you're like ah
and then the band takes a break you're
all like oh this is the best part of the
night
if i walk into a bar and they're playing
elephants gerald i'm like i'll stay for
a few for sure
the billy holiday yeah that's the best
but by the way
is that uh is that the bar i think it is
that's the fat black pussycat behind me
right now if you're watching us on on
youtube this is the fat black pussycat
our home comedy club part of the comedy
cellar which i miss so much so
the amount of nights we've had [ __ ]
faced here mark oh my god
countless and i've just gone in and out
of that curtain so many times
it's hilarious it's beautiful i miss i
miss it i
miss just the hang i miss the shitty
paninis i miss the chicken wings i miss
the
the drinks you order and they hand it to
you in a pint glass i've never drank a
negroni in a pint glass except for
the [ __ ] fat black pussycat yeah yeah
they pile it on but uh boy you gotta
love it i'm there tonight i'm at the
cellar tonight i just i'm behind the
plexiglas but it's it's something
i don't know if we're supposed to say
that oh oh [ __ ]
it's dinner having dinner there dinner
we're having dinner
uh all right well whatever what else i
got some pet peeves
oh yeah hit me so my mom will do this i
love my mom but
my mom will like i'll be like i'll be on
the phone with her and i'm like alright
i'm walking into the
uh to the the you know the bodega just
grabbed some quick
food from my mom's like why don't you
just order your food why don't you order
instead i'm like
i'm walking in like what you want me to
just and she's like why don't you i'm
like why do order food all the time but
i also
i also want to eat right now right right
you're trying to just i'm like they
don't like fresh direct ain't delivering
tonight
these are like like just how i'm not
i'll order in seamless sometimes
like i'm doing like these are groceries
i want for the house these are like
necessities that's why you go to the
corner store i'm wearing a mask
yeah oh is she getting on you about
covet or
oh totally yeah okay i thought it was a
health thing
it's been it's been it's been a year i'm
taking it seriously
let's you know yes let's calm down
everybody you're
definitely taking it seriously you're
allowed to go out i mean we're all at
grocery stores you got to eat
but yeah i think that's that's a little
that's a little excessive wendy liebman
uh great joke writer had a great tweet
the other day about how we landed on
mars
yet she hasn't been to a grocery store
in 11 months
[Laughter]
wow that's funny that's solid so good so
good
she kind of invented that whole thing
that that kind of sly misdirect thing
yeah you're right it's like there's a
type of misdirect joke and it's like
wendy leibman like
she like took it up a level like to
another type where it was like
i'm tricking you every time yep yep yep
exactly and if you
if you blink you miss one of them
there's so many and they're so quick
yeah she's great i'm with you on that
that's silly like
yeah i'm not unsafe i'm wearing the mask
i'm at a store i wash my hands when i
get home we're good
i gotta i got two more they're short
ones all right people who tell
stories about boring vacations like
if you went to rome i'll give it to you
i'll listen
i'll listen to a little bit i don't need
to hear a story about you going to
[ __ ] toledo
ohio okay do i have to hear a [ __ ] do
i have to hear a four minute bit about
the hilton inn
right right yeah that's crazy that's
that those people should know better and
if you're going to toledo keep it to
yourself like that
you should be embarrassed keep it to
yourself is such a [ __ ] great thing
to say to someone that they're going
to keep it to yourself yeah yeah
yeah that's silly i mean come on how
boring are you
awful last one is people who try to
one-up
you with their shitty story like like
you're going in for like you
you're venting to someone you wanna like
like ah that sucks that sucks
when people go you think that's bad oh
yeah they're trying to [ __ ] tai chi
their [ __ ] into your [ __ ]
yeah you're taking my negative energy
you're transmitted to your negative
energy it's tai chi but with
with venting yes that's so true it's
like hey i need the pity right now don't
steal my pity they're stealing thunder
and stealing pity
it's two different things stealing rain
maybe
yeah yeah yes yes stealing rain that's a
horrible uh
prince album yeah
no you're so true that and that's why uh
the the the hasidic jews and the blacks
always had the like not enough slaver
not holocaust slavery holocaust that was
always a big thing
stealing rain what um give me a
uh should we do a bit i get we gotta we
gotta start wrapping up but i i wanna
say a toast i i wrote down a [ __ ]
toast oh i'm excited i i
forgot to do it give me your toast this
will be a new segment this was just me
being a douche and uh it's not even a
thing in life i just want to
throw out a google to toast and i liked
it so much
life is a waste of time time is a waste
of life so why not get wasted all the
time and have the time of your life
all right did you steal that from a from
a t-shirt store on bourbon street
i'm not as think as you drunk i am
i wanna champagne all my real friends
and real pain all my sham friends
hey that's a great line
that's up there with a george carlin's
uh don't don't sweat the petty things
and don't pet the sweaty things
oh that's a good one that's carlin he
can do it all he can do it all
big bits commentary jokes we should tell
you guys before we do our bits
uh you know subscribe leave us a five
star review on itunes
uh we got a patreon at patreon.com we
might be drunk pod
and you can email us at we might be
drunk pod at gmail.com send us a joke
send us a pet peeve
a recommendation a drink that we should
be having i had a couple
cool drinks in mind and i turned out i
didn't have dry vermouth
so i will be doing that next week but uh
should i read a quick one like a pet
peeve or something before
yeah just to give them a taste of what
we do we read these on the podium all
right
here's from thomas he's a pet peeve big
fan yada yada pet peeves
when you tell someone something and they
say i'd believe that
what do you mean you'd believe that are
you not believing everything else also
why wouldn't you also
you would believe that you don't simply
to be you don't simply believe it that's
that's good
i love that i think he's dead on i'm
with this guy i can hang with this guy
let's see he's got another oh this is an
mba pet peeve let's we'll put that
another one let's do it let's do one
more pet peeve let's see
all right all right one more pet peeve
one pet peeve from
i hate when people wear pants and don't
wear long socks with them i'm not
talking about guys with rolled up pants
to purposely show their socks i.e my
cousin
[Laughter]
and i give him plenty of [ __ ] for it but
rather the average dude wearing jeans
that reach his ankle and he sits down
if you're if you're cold then wear long
socks with your pants if you're not cold
then put on some shorts
drives me sounds like carlin right here
yeah drives me crazy when i see a guy
with
his ankles exposed under a pant leg uh
interesting yeah
i've never thought about that that's
never bothered me but uh
yeah to each his own i mean i have a
friend he's like if you wear flip-flops
around me we're not friends anymore i'm
like
all right i love flip-flops i don't know
what the problem is but i don't
understand
giannis giannis hates man feed he's like
have you got your feet around me
hates it so i met up with him once in
the summer i had shorts and flip-flops
on he's like get out of here he
he wait maybe go home no we didn't no he
didn't but it was
it was i was like oh what what do you
care like are you into my feet or not
under my feet if you're not i know i'm
just
whatever i don't i i my only issue with
flip-flops is like if you're slowing
down the walking
yes that'll give you i'll give you that
but yeah i'm fine look whatever you want
to wear i i could give a [ __ ] but i i i
understand maybe like visually that's
weird you see like the
i do agree that like in the winter it is
weird to see the shorts
the short socks with the long pants but
also like i don't i don't give a [ __ ]
i wear long thermal socks every time
like it's [ __ ] february man
yeah yeah i [ __ ] marina wool right
but here this is why this this bothers
me because this guy's inconsistent
there's something going on here because
he doesn't mind seeing my ankles in the
summer but he hates seeing my ankles in
the winter
so is it an ankle issue or is it a
seasonal issue
i don't understand the beef i think it's
an attire issue i think if you're
rocking he doesn't like the long pants
with the short socks he just wants the
short
the long socks with the long pants and
the short socks with the short pants
or shorts okay seems i think this guy's
reaching for a peeve
that's a good reaching for a peeve is
good
when you sit down to peeve i like that
all right let's tell me a bit you're
working on
oh man well i'm working on a one-liner
and it's uh it's inside of a bigger bit
but tell me if this is stupid and i'll
i'll put it in a vault and throw it in
the river
uh
so i tell you how everybody complains
now online like everybody's complaining
so much we're all complaining
even my deaf friend complained so much i
had to put him in handcuffs
do you get it or is it too silly no yeah
sign language of course i guess all
right all right is that is that
ridiculous
handcuffs problem was uh he's into being
tied up
that's a weird thing too with like deaf
people if they get tied up like
if they're into like you know bondage
and [ __ ] that means they can't speak how
do you say how do you sell the safe word
oh that's a whole nother that's a great
angle with that
another angle baby i like it i like it
yeah anglin
my deaf friend was tied up the other
night he was speechless
that's good okay okay i didn't i didn't
know if it was too jokey but it's in
it's in a quick thing with the other
stuff so
you can get away with joking your
delivery you're able to kind of
you know you get that kind of you do
enough in a row that you can kind of be
silly like i think you kind of say it
tongue-in-cheek too
yeah yeah very tongue-in-cheek and you
know it's like that vegan joke uh
i'm walking on eggshells around my vegan
friend he really hates that it's just
quick in and out
as i'm just trying to get as many jokes
as i can so uh that's a good joke
oh thanks some people give me [ __ ] like
oh easy uh you know shecky green i'm
like well i'm just trying to get as many
in here
you know what the jokes are silly i i
got no issue
i like the idea of it i haven't heard it
all right that's one of those i it feels
like henny youngman should have done
that or somebody
remember you said a joke how do blind
guys know when they're done wiping their
ass
[Laughter]
that's so great that's because it's like
yes that's a great point
i love robert schimmel so much i love
sherlock
i was at sea world they were selling
fish sticks i was like i'm good
oh what are these the acts that [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
yeah even better i love it this is my
idea so i went on a date with a girl who
was a she was a conspiracy theorist like
literally all of them she believed in
she was like i'm in a con it was like it
was draining i was like oh my god all
these [ __ ] conspiracy theories
she texts me i don't believe you don't
want to see me again i was like yeah you
do believe in q anon
you know what i mean and then right and
then and then she goes is this for real
and i said yes like sandy hook this is
for real
okay oh that's great all right i think
we got that great bit
bam oh i love that
hot ep oh yeah great this is a fun one
keep listening keep
keep subscribing keep sending us your uh
your pet mail emails we might be drunk
pod
at gmail.com subscribe to the patreon
patreon.com we might be drunk pod
i'm i'm loving this i'm having somebody
send us uh drink ideas too what drinks
you like
we had a drink last week i've never even
heard of that i want to try and uh tell
your
tell your sober friends who probably
miss drinking we can fill a hole
uh that you've been trying to fill and
your family hates you so
uh yeah tell a friend spread the love
spread the word
spread the cheeks and uh yeah and this
is for the sober people too baby
we love you we know it's tough you know
what i'll do a quick toast before we get
out of here here's a toast to the sober
people because
it ain't easy i've said it before you're
still going to things
that's a [ __ ] fight we love you to
the uh to the sober alkies out there
you're here nice you're still loukies
yeah i
literally and figuratively i couldn't do
it
so uh more power to you well done
thank you thanks for listening guys